deux pianos en veux tu en voilà ce soir
dans l'os un beau jeu d'abord ici au
théâtre d'hérouville et ensuite nous
irons théâtre déconne djoko et on va
tout de suite se au théâtre des cordes
pense là où ça bouge nous sommes au
théâtre des cordes ce soir pour la
réouverture du théâtre et je suis avec
marilù marini
mais qu'est ce que vous faites là jamais
ragarde les pieds pour me distraire
je trouve pas ça très distrayant moi
parce que ce n'est pas votre et pillé la
journée une rêveuse et autres moments un
spectacle adapté de deux pièces de
copies dramaturge écrivain dessinateur
l'artiste touche-à-tout argentin est
mort à paris 1985 et les seuls points de
sera confiée lorsqu'un troisième réveil
sonne
elle a à peine arrêté la sonnerie quand
un quatrième puis un cinquième elles
coupent dans les parcs a rétabli
sonnerie qui sait mieux le pipi il y a
de quoi commencer sa journée des
mauvaises ce n'est pas seulement un
humoriste c'est un surtout c'est un
poète
c'est un grand poète qui a là
l'élégance et la gentillesse de dire des
choses très profondes avec une légèreté
qui nous fait sourire mais qui nous fait
réfléchir
il n'y avait que quelqu'un comme mary
lou qui pouvait le porter parce que
c'est ça aussi qui est beau c'est c'est
que elle a aussi comme elle le disait
cette histoire à l'intérieur d'elle même
c'est une chose très intime et qu'elle
comprend qu'elle a vécu et qu'elle
qu'elle retransmettrait bien il s'agit
d'une histoire qui que je connais bien
que je veux qu une histoire copie s'est
nourrie en fait des tous ont vécu en
argentine la journée d'une rêveuse et
autre moment au théâtre des cordes à
caen tous les soirs jusqu'à vendredi à
20h
à
au coeur de ce théâtre des robin pour
bien
nistos logis le rpm histologie c'est
quoi c'est une maladie c'est quoi non
pas du tout on va dire que c'est plutôt
la science
la science de l'étude du pianiste et non
pas du piano ses papiers à nos logis ces
pianistes au logis vous l'avez tous
reconnu ce sont paul cheval blanc avec
sa belle mèche blonde parce qu'il le
vaut bien
ah non non non c'est pas du tout un
court parce que j'ai vraiment pas la
prétention de donner des leçons à qui
que ce soit ç'a déjà réglé numéro un non
c'est plutôt dans le spectacle
j'explique j'explique un peu ma vie de
pianiste ou parce que comme de nombreux
musiciens on m'a forcé à faire du piano
quand j'avais 8 ans et une fois que je
jouais plutôt pas trop mal on m'a dit
qu'en fait je serais jamais pianiste
finalement en tout cas pas pianiste
classique et après j'ai
j'ai fait des tas d'autres choses je
fais de la variété du jazz du rock n
roll du métal la techno la salle saâda
ta dah dah
et
e
oui
cette mélodie qui est par un peu
ringarde
what
traité comme un bon standard de jazz
m
pour ce concert de simon fâché que je
vous présente donc grand pianiste qui
sait tout jouer
vous le verrez si vous venez demain soir
ici au théâtre d'hérouville vous verrez
le spectacle vous vrai qu'il n'est pas
seul puisque norbert genvrin et l'
orchestre d'hérouville vous êtes aussi
présents puis c'était à l'heure
six mois une version solo de son
spectacle dans la france entière et
l'existence de cette version avec
orchestre m'a tout de suite attiré qui
sont une excellente idée pour la saison
estivale d'hérouville
venez vraiment demain soir ici au
théâtre d'hérouville voir simon fâche
est aussi d'ambert genvrin quitte à la
direction d'orchestre d'hérouville un
grand spectacle à la fois extrêmement
musicale mais qui ne manque pas d'humour
vous l'avez compris c'est demain soir à
20h merci monsieur merci logo eux aussi
jouent avec les standards de la musique
classique ou de la variété porte à
bretelles en concert à l'espace coisel à
centrer sur orne où saint martin de
fontenay puisque l'espace cause elle est
sur les deux communes
c'est vendredi soir